[تصفيق]
في
2018 قررت اني اصعد اعلى قمه في
افريقيا جبل كلمنجارو
اوكي اتوقع
انه حلو
طبعا قررت اني اصعد هذا الجبل لسبب هذيك
الفتره من
حياتي كنت في حاله من التوتر وايضا ما كنت
راضيه بالحياه اللي انا كنت عايشتها كانت
عباره عن عمل وعباره عن عائلتي وبس
فبالنسبه لي ما كانت الحياه الكافيه لي
وكنت متامله ان يوم من الايام راح اوصل
لهدف حياتي ايش هو ما
اعرف الجبل هذا الاعلان ماله كان مكتوب
عليه اذا صعدتي هذا الجبل راح يغير حياتك
الى الابد فقررت اني اسجل
الجبل والمرشد السياحي قاللي نور اليوم
اللي راح تسجلين فيه للجبل هو اليوم اللي
راح يتغير حياتك 180 درجه مش للوصول للجبل
بالنفس ولكن اللحظه اللي انت سجلتي فيها
للجبل حياتي
تغيرت صار انه عباره عن
تدريب صرت فجاه اركض فجاه صرت اشارك
بالسباقات صرت اشيل اثقال ف اللي صار انه
حياتي تمحورت حول اني اتدرب فقط لهذا
الهدف وايضا كان لازم اتجهز للاغراض اللي
راح البسها فاضطريت اني اطلع واسافر
واشتري الاشياء اللي انا احتاجها
للجبل وصلت للجبل تعرفت على ناس اول مره
اشوفهم في حياتي كلنا جايين لاهداف مختلفه
ولكن كلنا جايين انه نصعد هذا الجبل ونوصل
للقمه بدينا اول شيء بين الادغال وبعدها
دخلنا بين الصحاري ودخلنا في جو الوديان
واخر شيء نوصل
للجليد خلال المشوار طبعا المشوار هذا
لمده سبعه ايام ست ايام صعود واخر يوم
نزول
وصلنا لليوم الرابع وصلنا ليوم الرابع
منهكين جدا كنا جدا تعبانين كان فينا توتر
كان فينا خوف ليش لان وصلنا لارتفاع على
ارتفاع 4000 فوق سطح البحر هذا الارتفاع
بالنسبه لاجسادنا شي مش طبيعي لان نسبه
الاكسجين عندنا اساسا راح ينزل كثير على ه
الارتفاع فكنا واي تعبانين كنا نحاول ان
نتا قلم مع الارتفاع الجديد لحظتها المرشد
شاف توترنا وخوفنا وكنا شكينا في
استمراريتنا لهذا المشوار فالمرشد قال نور
لا تفكرين في الايام القادمه ولا تفكرين
في يوم القمه فقط ركزي على اليوم اللي انت
فيه وعلى الهدف لليوم عيشي اليوم بيومه
عشان تستمتعين بالمشوار وتستمتعين
باللحظات اللي راح تعيشينها في كل يوم
بهذا الجبل وبالفعل طبقت هذا الشيء صرت
اعيش كل يوم بيومه بتعبه بارهاق بجماليته
بكل شيء لدرجه اني وصلت لمرحله اني نسيت
يوم القمه تماما وصلنا ليوم
القمه وانا ما مستوعبه ف المرشد قال انت
اليوم راح تصعدون للقمه راح تنامون العصر
وتصحو بالليل فانا قلت ليش ليش اليوم يعني
ايش صاير قال اليوم يوم القمه فانا انصدمت
جتلي صدمه ان كيف صار متى صار متى لحقنا
متى وصلنا بس يوم وصلت لهذاك اليوم وصلت
باريحيه اكبر وصلت بثقه اكبر وصلت يعني
بشكل اني انا اليوم مستعد اني اصعد
الجبل فبدي على ضوء القمر نمشي خطوه بخطوه
فولي فولي على قولتهم
ا ووصلنا الى
القمه طبعا لحظتها ما استوعبت قلت اوكي
انا الحين وصلت خلصت شلت على معمار خلاص
خلصنا صح اوكي ما حسيت باي شيء ثاني غير
ان انا وصلت للقمه وتصورت والحين اريد
انزل ففي مشوار النزول من الجبل بديت
استوعب الشيء اللي انا سويته شوي شوي مش
مره واحده ولكن شوي شوي حسيت انه الحين
انا تدربت كل هال الشهور وسافرت ودربت
وسويت كل هذا عشان هذه اللحظه لا طلع
الموضوع كثير اكبر من انه انا و وصلت
للقمه طلع الموضوع ان انا حياتي اساسا
تغيرت من يوم ما انا قررت اني اصعد هذا
الجبل ف بدا تعلمت عده اشياء من هذا
المشوار اللي الحين اللي قضيته في خلال
هذا الجبل الشيء الاول اللي تعلمته ان
لازم نعيش اليوم بيومه مهما كان الهدف
كبير ونحط اهداف صغيره ومصغره علشان نقدر
ناديها خلال اليوم عشان نوصل ل هدفنا
الكبير هذا الشيء الاول اللي تعلمته الشيء
الثاني انه لازم نمشي بخطوات جدا بطيئه
بولي بولي على اساس نتعلم من خلال هذا
المشوار وايضا نكسب كثر ما نقدر خلال
مشوارنا لاهدافنا والشيء الثالث اللي
تعلمته الانسان احيانا مش دائما على حسب
الشخص حلو انه يحط نفسه في
بيئه بين الحياه والموت لان هذه البيئه
راح تغير حياتك وتخليك انسان جديد او تغير
تغيرك من الداخل الى الخارج وراح تغير
حياتك من كل النواحي هذه النقطه الثالثه
اللي تعلمتها طبعا بعد ما رجعت استوعبت
انه صار عندي شغف جديد واهداف جديده قررت
اني اصعد اعلى قمه في كل قاره اللي هي سبع
قمم وبدا مشواري من بعد ما صعدت جبل كلم
جاره
قدرت
فقررت اني اصعد اسراع قمم حول العالم
وقدرت اني اوصل اعلى قمه في اوروبا اللي
هي قمه البروس وبعدها قدرت اني اوصل ايضا
قمم اخرى في النيبال من بينهم وصلت الى
قاعده افرست ان شاء الله هذا راح يكون
الحلم الاكبر لا نشتغل عليه
وايضا وصلت ل ما وصلت القمه ولكن حاولت
اني اصعد اعلى قمه في جنوب امريكا طبعا
راح تقولون ان اوه ما شاء الله يعني هذه
صعدت كل ه الجبال ولكن انا ما وصلت لكل
القمم لهال الجبال في بعضهم وصلت وفي
بعضهم ما وصلت طبعا واحد يمر في ظروف
احيانا في مشواره بس مو شرط انه راح يوصل
للهدف من اول مره في شيئين الواحد ما يقدر
يتحكم فيهم في الجبل الجو وايضا مرض
الارتفاع وانا عشت هالشيء
مرتين ولكن تعلمت كثير واكتسبت معارف
اكتسب اكتسبت اشياء جديده في حياتي من
خلال مشواري لهال
الجبار
طبعا رجعت رجعت لارض الواقع ورجعت لسطح
البحر وقمت اطبق كل اللي تعلمته واللي
ذكرت لكم اياه باومي بايامي وتغيرت حياتي
180 درجه صرت اطبق كل اللي تعلمته في
حياتي في وظيفتي
في ترقيتي اخذت وقتي في ترقيتي وايضا في
مشاريعي اللي حاليا جس اشتغل عليها مع
الناس اللي تعرفت عليهم خلال المشوار
رسالتي هي اذا عندك هدف كبير في حياتك لو
ايش ما كان
امشي خطوه بخطوه بول بولي وراح توصل لهدفك
فوق ما تتصور
شكرا